The fastest way to support touch
is to change the UI in respond
to a DOM elements change in state.
DOM elements can be in one of
the following states default,
hover, focus or active.
To change our UI for
each of these states,
we need to apply styles to the following
pseudo classes active, focus and
hover, as shown here and
here are the results.
On most mobile browsers hover and
focus states will apply to
an element after it's being tapped.
So, consider carefully
what size you set, and
how they will look to the user
after they finish their touch.
Bear in mind that anchor tags and
buttons may have different
behaviors in different browsers.
So assume in some cases the hover will
remain, and in others focus will remain.
Here you could see it in action, when
we're clicking on each of the buttons,
and it's left with a different style.
You could open dev tools and see what
are the pseudo states that we gave for
each of the buttons.
In iOS, in particular, we don't
have an active state by default.
So check the instructor notes for
a shim.